[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello everyone how are you
doing it's a wonderful wonderful day
here and we're gonna be playing some you
coozes six Miguel aren't we yes we are
I'm so excited to games coming out in
April
but we have an early look and an early
build of the game and there we go yeah
we are gonna check out I'm switching
over to it so people can just see the
game this latest version of Camaro Cho
which has been the staple location of
Yakuza since the beginning yes
so we're what are we what are we we're
only allowed to show certain things
we're only allowed to show the story
within reason and no further than
chapter 4 so there we go we got our
limit set in we're gonna have a good
time but atlas / Sega PR did give me the
clearance to load a chapter 5 save file
on the condition I don't show anymore
plot but it just so happens that in
chapter 5 there are a couple minigames
that are easier to access than earlier
in the game
yeah oh here we are
you know the one thing that I can't get
over like going through this series is
just how much it's it's just gone up
like fidelity wise graphics fidelity and
just the animation quality it's it's so
pretty now yeah and you know you can
count on seeing certain things in Camuto
every time you visit this in the game
like you have your Club Sega you have
the movie theater we're here and yeah in
the bowling alley
oddly enough I actually stayed at the
APA hotel oh really my last trip to
Japan let's see so
this finds Kiryu back in Komuro cho in
2016 and he is trying to find Haruka huh
as you can see you look all the detail
in the town it's it's come a long way
since the original game in 2005 yeah for
real though we've got a request for mr.
dreadful and the twitch chat find some
cats find some cats they've said it
twice so I think we need to do I know
what he's talking about
unfortunately accessing the
quote-unquote cats oh I think I believe
is passed um chapter 4 those are
embargoed cats we can't do it mr.
dreadful I'm sorry but when when we
can't believe it
there will be cats you know one thing
that's very refreshing and something
that I think is long overdue is the fact
that you could actually finally access
did you say refreshing when you went up
to a machine perfect this is like this
doesn't make the convenience stores
obsolete because these are actually like
battle boosts as opposed to healing
items oh nice
is there gonna be a beta ask Seth gaming
on YouTube not a beta but a demo a demo
and it's really it's a all signs point
to it being a really good demo it's
coming out at the end of this month and
the best part is you'll be able to
transfer your progress to the whole game
so here's beat these boys up take them
for a ride Miguel Sega Jacob says I'm
couldn't up stumbling into the cat cafe
in Camarillo it could happen ellipsis
I think it's implying something
man I so we've got what's the fighting
system like in this game compared to the
other ones I know a lot of people
probably just came off of like 0 or
maybe even 5 if they are trying to like
keep up story-wise interestingly enough
it does not carry over the the multiple
fighting styles that a lot of fans got
used to in cooiiy and 0 no use the d-pad
to switch between the rush the rush
or the beast the fighting style in this
game is actually uh it's sort of a
little bit more focused I would say ok
and it's almost like a throwback to the
original game as I see it it looks a lot
a lot more like the older like stuff you
had in like 3 4 5 kind of like a
straight RPG leveling up kind of area
right so let's get into this fight and
one of the really one of the really cool
things that I that is I would say an
improvement is the fact that you can
actually run away oh right you could
lure enemies into businesses are you
know what is even happening these guys
are not coordinating it at all so we can
take the fight into smile burger rather
than a smile burger right yet you had no
respect for that glass at all sure use
the chair these guys to be just as
brutal as ever I love it oh man
wonderful oh yeah and the poor poor lady
in the back
tsegga Jacob points out that narrative
Lee it wouldn't make sense to carry over
the same kind of fighting style stuff
because dragon is his style right and
you Cruz's hero is when he's just
starting out it was this is quickly
decades later so he's he's evolved so do
we do we have any of the the like the
cut scenes where someone like instigates
a fight anymore dollars it all kind of
seamless now it's pretty seamless but
obviously there's the there's gonna be
the boss fight so yeah this lady is not
too happy that I brought the fight into
her burger establishment get out and
don't ever come back you will never get
a burger in this town again
how's that you really just let let just
play some story missions and the the
burger place will eventually get
repaired and they won't remember that
you were changed out the staff cuz
they've just they can't deal with that
that's a giant traffic cone and he'll
love it
oh yeah the giant traffic cone has been
a staple in the yuccas s series since
the beginning I believe popo convenience
store Oh someone else are you know
there's so many angry people around here
I am really into the seamless thing of
it like the fact that a fight can happen
just kind of like it just did is really
rad oh my goodness I didn't pull off
that Kiki I better try it again of
course if I didn't here though
I'm further blacklisted ah yup this is
this is exactly what I came here for
start punching through those there's no
reason for him to do this but it's good
Jesus
there we go
ah yeah this is fantastic I so many so
many good changes
what's the frame rate I it doesn't look
like it's quite 60 I don't know the
exact number so I can't tell you other
than just looking with my eyes yeah
there is a man who is actually gonna
beat you up and you're just punching
these rags up but it doesn't look like
it's 60 but it looks like it might be a
little bit higher than 30 maybe a bit
variable yeah and they got ragdoll
physics now for the the guys that you're
punching which I'm very into oh there we
go 30 FPS we've got confirmation new
engine Sega Jacob I'm very happy that
you're here
oh it's Daigo yeah Oh Jacob she used to
use tell us we could we can happen to
one of those cat cafes you know okay I
mean it's all up to where the adventure
takes us Jesus I love it
go talk to this poor guy it's his first
day on the job he's like I finally got a
really cool way to don't ever come back
already paid off your pre-order for the
highest to your version of the game I
can't wait same I gotta get those those
glasses that the game comes with not my
glasses but drink glasses
I won't come across enough hugs on this
live stream but so I gotta ask they're
one of my favorite actions in the game
is the one where he takes out the
cigarette is that still good I have not
encountered that so you gotta like you
know what you know what I'm talking I
right yes no one were you gotta like
push down on the d-pad like what with
cigarette
you kind of go in cop that's so good
you like lights it and there's a hammer
on the ground he lights it many like
flicks it at the guy it's like my
favorite thing I don't
yeah right especially after this many
games like this guy just hanging out in
this one area black off is it guy in
that white suit beating everyone up
again let's take a break and play an
arcade game and you guys can check out
how much or how little a bug it has
changed oh yeah he won't see the vault
there we go that's real good the
previous games did not have vaulting he
looks like it just moves a lot better in
this one which is great so what's your
outrun nice nice hang on
Space Harrier Space Harrier is a good
time up here multiple floors art odd
arts my favorite arcade game and fantasy
zone who can give let's give the Africa
map or track in super hang on super hang
on your your arcade game of choice so
your favorite out of the out of the set
I'm more of an outrun person but I'm a
little rusty
alright that's that's fair see I'm also
kind of an outrun guy like outrun pretty
pretty well not very good at it
but I'm a fan
in its it's basically exactly how you
remember it if you if you'd played it
and we've also got the really cool like
outline of the actual like arcade
machine going on it seems which is
really rad yeah oh yeah it's uh it's a
little bit cleaner looking I mean yeah I
mean you don't have the the CRT lines
and this is this is real intense right
now will do fine I'm pretty confident
they'll be able to clear this see is
there another arcade with newer games
who wants I can tell you that poyo poyo
and Virtua Fighter 5 final showdown
actually make are available in this game
as well yeah like being the entirety of
the arcade version the arcade version as
opposed to the more fleshed out console
version was like Virtua Fighter 5
showdown or something if I don't show
that final showdown there you go yeah so
that's all in there that's a good time
lots of fun games inside your games you
can game while you game so um so bad I
mean you told me that you've actually
beaten all the up side games so you are
pretty much set for this right so yeah I
I feel really bad about it because like
I got I started playing like hardcore in
the series in 3 like I played a little
bit of one and that was like back when I
wasn't like oh cool it sort of beat him
up game sure played a little bit of two
and I I got in three like hardcore I was
like this is like my my second favorite
series on the PlayStation I loved it so
much I need to play for I was sitting
there hanging out on like tumblers for
people who were like get all these games
localized so I was really happy when
they finally brought five over and then
I just I got so caught up in doing
everything that I just never finished it
and I found was it will come back around
to it this year and actually get through
it nice so I'm I'm ready I'm set for six
very excited for that this would be a
nice segue to bring up the
that I had the honor of collaborating
with our video producer John Luke on I
guess what we call season 2 who of our
history of series happens to be Yakuza
so we I think we've got that in the
pipeline and I think we'll be posting
that in less than a week should be
coming up soon but we are looking at the
chat you guys I see it's Juan wolf girl
Arjun I'm just really excited about
Yakuza 6 and I feel bad because I
haven't been able to pay as much
attention to guys as I want to but I'm
here I'm I see you I see you I'm sorry
but we're not doing giveaways
unfortunately not not today we're just
doing a really cool kind of but never
say never when it comes to giveaways on
sagen atlas games and in your future
says if you played all the Yakuza games
you probably like to know that all the
games until six were essentially made in
the same engine this is true that very
that is a point I do make in the history
of and so you can actually you know I
mean there's there's very subtle touches
I think Ben you could probably you
already notice in this game in terms of
just like how much oh didn't make it
game over
you'll see certain little touches sort
of like just showing like the how much
better this engine is oddly enough I
noticed like how much better defined
everyone's cheekbones are is are we
looking at the cheekbone up raises that
check out is that we are all right I'm
in it's that new engine
it's that new engine hotness no problem
keep the good work don't blame me for
wanting to see more of this yeah I feel
bad because I I it's a thing that I
really kind of try to do whenever I'm on
a live free more than anything is
actually talk to you guys because like
why why would you show up if we don't
talk to you like that's that's really
dumb and I get kind of self-conscious
about it you know trying yeah and like
many of the other previous Yakuza games
the main
menu does offer this reminisce section
where you could get recaps of the
previous games oh that's good that is
the thing that that actually helped me a
lot when I was picking up three is I
actually sat there for like like it felt
like two or three hours a long time ago
to just catch myself up on the story
because I didn't know what was going on
when I was playing the first two it was
really helpful say we should do some bad
oh yeah and the fact that I actually put
a pin on the map that's one of the many
let me say you just marked a place
that's one of the many quality of life
improvements you'll you'll find in this
game aside from the other stuff that we
did bring up nice the being able to run
away from from fights also auto-saving
ooh yes Jimmy wants know who's your
favorite character in the series I'm a
carrier guy I mean I have a lot of
friends who are really into goro majima
you can't go wrong with either of those
two but I feel like I feel like my boy
Akiyama doesn't get enough attention I
like him a lot like he was great but
akiyama's got like that really good like
golden golden heart he's a good good boy
I love him a lot yeah can you drive a
car in this game no noticed not unless
something happens in the story that I
don't know about but it's it's not a
Yakuza staple to drive cars though there
have been driving minigames in the past
this is true Google one home run will be
nice I'm really terrible at this
you're doing all right yeah at least I'm
making contact
I actually know which batting Center
this is modeled after oh really I
actually went on a on a date with my
wife there on one of the nights that we
were spending in Kabukicho which is what
Komuro chose modeled after oh there we
go oh we did it just like that
oh I was busy looking at the chat
that's that's fine see that's what it is
you get caught up in trying to look at a
chat and you get your home run you're
like it's time to see see what everyone
thinks but yeah but far there's the best
game in the series that's time I'm
hoping I'm I'm so excited to finally get
my hands on it and play it Yakuza is a
more about story and such versus crazy
stunts to stuff and sandbox driving
games this is very true Yakuza is a
really interesting game series if you
don't know much about it where it's got
like it's really intense like crime
drama story that's very serious but it
provides a lot of levity in the side
quests that are just some of the most
silly things you've ever seen in a video
game and it it comes together in a
really nice package and it's it's a heck
of an experience you can't really find
in a lot of other games I mean in terms
of the levity I think that's one of the
reasons why people regard
yokas as zero so highly just it really
took those subplots the absurdity was so
plus to another level and I'm not I'm
not expecting anything to the level of
the Nugget bowling yeah storyline but I
still have a lot of Yakuza 6 to play so
maybe there will be something like that
let's go ahead and move the plot along
see people asking about well who was
asking more about minigames and they're
talking about having more stuff with
more depth like the kraang clan creator
oh yeah we're gonna be all the Jews
gonna check that out in a little bit oh
hey you I'm glad people are still still
fans of her oh yeah so if you need a
little bit of a recap power cup in
Yakuza 5 had a short-lived career as an
idol and
without going into too much detail she
retired and but it's not without having
you know gained her own legion of fans
like this young girl who is having
because she retired she's having her
this girl is having a really hard time
trying to find essentially
okay Haruka schwag oh man so if I were
to see a man like cosmic here on the
street I would definitely think that he
has the hook-up yeah give me all those
those cool CDs signed CDs and such whoo
boy yeah cue the dramatic music yeah
these handshake events that this girl
referencing is actually meaning it yeah
it was it was really interesting too cuz
this is the first time we kind of did
anything that was a little creepy though
to see the fans like smell their hands
it was a really good to shed some light
on that and the entire like Idol
lifestyle I guess Jason there are some
rhythm sections in the sense that we did
play some karaoke but I don't haven't
come across anything like resembled
dancing or or like any Idol style
mini-games
oh yeah and going back to the quality of
life improvements according to Saiga
Jacob everything every conversation is
voiced I was gonna say it doesn't seem
like we have the like I feel like this
would be one of the scenes where it has
like the Box up and just just the text
and need to say like the first word or
something right but it's it's completely
voice-acted so this triggers a mini game
I mean a side mission where we actually
do track down some swag awesome
what are some of the most absurd sipes
side stories you've seen there was one
involving an Alexa style like virtual
assistant okay all right and just things
got got real real wacky there yes I like
it but like you guys figure it out
I mean discover it on your own I haven't
played six yet myself but there's a
really fun double date one that happened
in five I think that put Carey you in a
really odd position that I had a fun
time playing through have you ever been
to Japan yeah I have not been to Japan
you should go to a Don Quixote I I want
to if anything because what yoku Xia has
taught me as they have that catchy theme
song playing all the time yes and I want
to be a part of that you can and you
could actually find that theme song on
YouTube oh really
never koozie games didn't have lots of
money at my younger age first console
was a story art games stories good then
you're in dude it's it's the perfect
perfect game if you want some good story
highly recommends David you'll be able
to play the demo later this month as I
said earlier it includes the prologue
and I believe like the first like a
chunk of chapter one and you'll be able
to use that save file when you get the
full game in April and I believe they
did put like a level cap so you can like
spend your February and March just
grinding out like random gangs in the
street but that's that's really rad that
they like a bento oh yeah this guy needs
it's my favorite objective to pop up in
the middle of screen this guy needs a
food bribe which is pretty reasonable I
actually already have a bento to give to
him it's like we planned this I love it
cure you for Tekken 7 please yes
more than more than most things so we go
to this that's also my favorite
objective to pop upholstery so we're
gonna meet your boy
my boy he's here yes ah so a little bit
of background on the story the Chinese
Triad have muscled their way into Coomer
Road show and they are trying they were
hunting down essentially anyone who's
associated with the Tojo clan okay and
that also includes Akiyama who has made
a living as its see back is he back with
his people sort of kinda okay all right
GUP I do like that you there are
pictures of all the food options that
are under consideration for purpose he's
so good yeah I'm actually noticing it
now I'm gonna get caught up and just pay
attention to the story and this I'm
gonna forget to talk yeah I could see
why a lot of people like a qiyama
he's his whole story I just love it so
much and I love how much his fate was so
much tied to the ending of yeah and you
don't even know it until you play
through was it EKU's afore that he comes
in yeah yeah so good you know I always
say that the sign of a good series is
that different fans have different
favorite installments and I think that
could probably apply to you so I think
one wave that yoga for stands out I
believe it's the first game that
actually allowed whether you plays
multiple characters yeah and I do make
this point that it was sort of like the
first glimpse of what the series could
be beyond curious I think I mean when I
was writing my script for the history of
I had the heart I remember coming to you
and asking for advice because I had the
hardest time trying to find like a game
series that had like a memorable
recurring ensemble
Cass right there aren't very many right
I thought of Dragon Age and gears of war
and I do think yeah cuz I has a very
strong recurring ensemble cast I mean
the kind that so many you can think of
so many characters that could hold their
own and like a spin-off games gotcha
God David Kwame is the remaster of
Yakuza 1 so it's it's like yeah piece of
one brought up to current time with some
extra stuff thrown in to kind of tie it
more to zero there's no news of a Kwame
to western release but you know we can
cross our fingers or something here's
hoping and then beyond that I won't get
a remake of three so I can play as my
favorite version of cosmic Uryu and a
swine shirt again and I should add a
side note that Kwame to actually runs on
the same on the dragon engine the same
engine that yucca six runs on oh man of
course everyone knows Edie please I love
this I love this too Don Juan I'll see
exactly everyone wants more Yakuza's
bring up bring me more more using sarios
i'm bouncing between saying yakuza who's
it because I'm trying to better myself
and actually saying it the right way
I have Frankie I have used some weapons
in the past I haven't actually gotten a
katana I should also add this a nice
time to mention that Sega if you're if
you really want a very thorough summary
and don't think you have time to
actually play all the office of games
you could check out the guy cuz I
experienced that Sega created
I believe you came back from Jacob to
probably talk about how you can access
this site it's probably on a cigarette
Lass's website jocks experience it just
gives like an entire like timeline and
plot summaries and it actually also
includes a digital graphic novel
and I believe you think Jacob said that
if you could if you pull if you read far
enough you'll actually find some codes
that can actually help you in your clan
bet I saw in some of the the trailers
that I've been processing because that's
one of the things that I do for this
site there have been some codes and some
of those trailers that have gone up for
four things nice
she's a checkout trailers for Yakuza six
if you want to get a hand up to moobot
calm down please
we've got some some some vocal tracks
going on for these these beat downs I
like it come on playing Monster Hunter
and I love it
same god David we actually had our
Monster Hunter Mondays live long mr. day
with ads after film you can die Ed's got
your number there we go there's that
link in that and the twitch f you want
to check out that yakuza experience give
you some codes get you some learn you
can learn on all at once
look let's say I have any many health
items maybe some toughness a for some
help or like oh the the boss health is
kind of displayed out now at the bottom
you know that's that's real handy
come on Takayama do some kicks yeah
go yeah oh that's what I'm here for
that's the good stuff all he's got a
knife now that's no good come on Edie
fight fair and by fight fair I mean
don't look at the fact that we have two
people here who want to throw out there
now to the Yakuza series one of my
favorite game series the stream because
it's just for that fun to watch like on
top of like actually like playing it
everything just looks so good and the
story gets sound tension god cheese come
on
so these games are only on PlayStation
and you're really rad if more people got
to play them I was kind of hoping like
back when Sega was doing a lot of their
reports to PC like with vanquish and
Bayonetta maybe we get like a yeah cause
I throw it in there or something but
that's a lot of work be kind of RAD
can't believe this how dare you team up
on me after you defeated the other five
people that rolled up in the sewer with
me
call me Takayama drag him okay good I
count on it edy
I'll find you we'll find you see ya take
it easy look out for the person in the
burger place they hate anyone who fights
in there
they won't let me back in also the Popo
oh yeah the convenience store can you
unlock moves when you beat the new japan
pro wrestling wrestlers in Yakuza 6
there's got to be some sort of cool
benefit in there for that I'm not sure
like ice I can't answer a lot of the
questions I haven't played the game
which is great cuz I don't exactly know
what's embargoed or not so I'm being
taken on a journey along with you guys
how are the controls Jay creator's wants
to know like have they changed me the
button layout stuff or anything or it's
all still kind of the same it's all
still the same I mean the like the
dodging and the blocking is very very
familiar despite a sense of urgency it's
true Sega Jacob has all the power he's
hanging out with us in the twitch chat
oh they want to know if there you get
anything for beating the
the Japanese pro wrestling characters
that are in the game I think there's
gonna be some benefit to that yeah other
than just being really cool that you get
to beat up some Japan wrestlers a gamer
Jeffro how you doing welcome to the show
that seamless like into buildings oh
yeah
still trying to get the hang of that no
actually don't have time to mess around
but I do want to check out are you still
in the middle of like a fight because
that way it's there's a major plot point
we need to address okay but should I
switch off of this or is there anything
we can't show and when you're loading
nope okay just wanted to be doubly sure
just yeah see all things give you
experience so it gives you that and you
can unlock them for use in the clan
creator possibly so there you go you
kind of kind of gather up all your
favorite wrestlers and put them in your
team that'll be a good time so we are
about to get a little meta with some
screen and screen screen high screen
action with a little more interesting
mini-games
okay Hyuk is a six it's it's not really
new territory in the series in the sense
that some of the yeah it's not no one
seems like it take off from the I I see
I see
hello it's me so we're gonna have a chat
with in a chat oh I like how she has her
chat come out as text chat when she says
it too so it's there's a rhythm game
here you're typing out your texts huh my
batteries need recharging says sexpot
9000 you mean it I love the little like
camera of here you down there
just hanging out yes so there's a live
chat minigame in Yonkers o6c this looks
very this is very familiar layout yes I
feel like I've seen this before
gladly
I wish then it typed it in all capital
letters like I want I want Kiryu to be
like the guy who actually like doesn't
know how to work a caps lock or
something but he's excited to be here
well this is he was introduced to live
chatting very very recently oh really
that seems like the fact that he is
typing only with his index fingers
please tell me that there's like a story
where someone introduced like an actual
cutscene or some there's like plot point
here you you should check this out you'd
be really into it I'm very excited yes
okay sexbots tell us your hobbies that's
a good question
whoa okay nevermind sexpot he doesn't
calm down that's a really long type out
that you got to do so how how far how
in-depth how far is this uh how long can
you it's it's pretty I mean it never
goes beyond pg-13 thank goodness okay
we're good we're fine every we're fine
everyone pissed I needed to find out cuz
I feel like I feel like we're heading
down a road it might hurt oh boy you
sure rotten oranges ha does he still run
an orphanage is not taking care of his
kids and he's wasting all of his his
money he find the first story mission in
this game it they say in like the very
dramatic font talk to the kids
ah you start off in the orphanage that's
the other one I really like besides
getting the sewer sewer talk to the kids
what so he's still taking care of those
kids he's spending his money on tokens
that should be spent on new additions
for for the orphanage to take care of
these kids
cosmic URI what happened to you just a
bit so needy I feel like she's just
talking to us exclusively uh
carriers that charming he is he's the
only one with a normal name in the chat
which is an interesting thing rock
lobster 4/20 shout-out to them I'm gonna
read this chat instead of the our chat
there's chanson chats happening right
now I would never pick a camp chat over
you guys please it's true you can just
be people up and get more yen to spend
on ventures whoo
okay what do I think
brilliant yeah Carrie who looks very
lost but he's having a good time okay I
think we did it good that was an
adventure imagine along with us for that
and we got to all experience that
together as a group you okay Ben you
know it was a great series I feel like
more people need to play it it's a good
time it's great time silly side stories
serious crime dramas good punches good
times good people
whoo doggy thank you for that so one of
the things I loved as the series
progressed is just the different kinds
of areas that became with introduced
beyond camera show and in Yakuza six
Kiryu ends up in hiroshima specifically
in the town of oh no michi and we are
about to check that out oh oh nice so
we're gonna check out the the other area
it's good too
I like this it's like watching a robot
mimicking human sexting you know that
might be like a character trait for
cosmic Uryu at this point which I'm kind
of down with I like how awkward he is
which is why I probably like that when
we were talking about most ridiculous
side missions like that that double date
one like sticks whoa he's taking the
jacket off he's got a baby
what okay I I think I know where the
babies from I know that cuz I've watched
the trailers as they've come out yeah
I've put the things together are you in
like a free room just holding on to a
baby okay all right I'm into it oh the
special are you getting it are you
getting a beer with that baby
sure let's get a beer with a baby they
won't start with B
we were able to did he tell you you
can't do this because you're with a
child oh okay
here we go where'd the baby go I don't
know where the baby went just put the
baby down like in a table next to him
and he's just like Aidid yeah I will
also add that there's a more sort of
nuanced approach to eating food normally
when your health was full you weren't
allowed to eat but now there's this
stomach icon that shows how much you're
allowed to eat to like some level of
benefit oh okay so you can't just like
constantly like eat a thing to always
take care of yourself you got a guy kind
of balance it out okay oh yes food day
care so Trina I should add yes
okonomiyaki is awesome
especially when you can make it on your
own
oh yeah we got two so we have this
there's a new sort of side mission
component called trouble mission this
time I got to take care of the bait I
got calmed the baby down
so there are different ways that you
could try to calm him down they're not
having a good time there's purple
dripping off of them is there crying
coming out of the controller it's like
the controllers the baby and you just
gotta figure out which of the actions
will come the baby down yes cuz he just
got food he got a beer he's trying to he
walks out of the restaurant he ended up
doing all four things but I see none of
this seems to be working so I'm just
gonna like just cycle through all these
upsy-daisy give them a swing maneuver oh
yeah you got to find the little cues
from curious comments she likes that
upsy-daisy
I got the music that's kind of go on in
the background that's kind of nice
you can only do this minigame in this
story segment okay so it's not like
you're stuck with a baby for like half
of the game that's good I'm glad that
this I I
I heard kind of about this I feel like
this I keep saying it because it's like
my new phrase I guess I feel like this
might be really close to PQ kool-aid oh
the baby signals the right motions with
its head that one's that one wants me to
swing him given that swing trying give
us the swing there you go
see it's just it's this entire time I
was using the sticks yeah I told the the
controller is the baby you've got to
hold the hold the controller like it's a
baby that makes sense did it took care
of that baby here you is the best dad oh
you got a trophy for taking care of the
baby I like this it's true Darklord this
is the game we're here this was
developed in 2016 16 yes it's very true
came out in December in Japan like like
late 2016 I believe huh you've learned
some rest that's a big bed for a baby
good I like I like this this is a good
this is a good look for here you
and meet whoever's got them generally
someone's at the door from the snack
palace here to talk to us about snacks
maybe the baby wants snacks his name of
the bar oh really
yeah I thought it was looking at like a
snack shack she just sells like Dorito
chips you so clueless it's not throw out
there the contrast between going to the
camp Shack site and then taking care of
a baby I see him there there are good
cheekbones oh yeah right
well there was a sympathetic written
goob said something that's it's probably
very true you can learn everything you
need from you who's a gaming for
everyday life it's here is a guy next
time oh hey key hunt anymore Luka don't
know that's caring in addition to my
knee
she's a babysitter she's got experience
that's how she knew hello unknown gamer
welcome tracking down the real dad the
the ditching dad that is correct
like in my mind cuz I don't I don't have
the entire like the whole thing I just
imagine he's like I'm gonna beat that
boy up how dare he mostly because that's
what Kiryu does a lot I should hit the
town again
do it dude we can explore a little bit
this is a really nice looking area
mm-hmm it's a pretty good contrast to a
lot of the other places you go to I like
it dark lord I feel the same way and I
dread waster all the time and some squid
sashimi and some fishermen suit oh
that's ID from real fishermen perfect so
real it's a real hearty meal oh man
I still wonder where the baby goes when
you're eating I I want to know it'd be
really cool if you can see like the
person just ordered from like holding
the baby like why are you doing this to
me oh uh are you gonna beat these boys
uh player holding a bit there we go
there's our baby holder that's what I'm
looking for
perfect like I look there's no question
he's just like yeah sure hold your baby
man go get these dudes up who tries to
punch someone holding a baby what kind
of person are you throw that point in
the ocean I know you could grab grab and
throw
yeah throw that boy into the water holy
cow
can we stop oh wait no they're blocking
though I can't believe this was a good
kick
we can't grab that he can't pick up
motorcycles weird that's the sentence I
actually said wanna fight holding the
baby maybe there'll be a chance some
point I feel like a baby just watching
the baby the baby's learning all your
cool dragon moves baby's gonna grow up
to become a fighter just like we're not
dad that's a real good throw I'm very
into that there we go
you ever drop a bike so hard it just to
sink right oh there we go
it's real good that's real real good I
say that Japan as a culture has a lot of
mindfulness so maybe taking care of your
baby is a thing I feel like it did
probably like if a man who's about to
get into a fistfight like like passes
you their child I feel like I feel like
you just have to hold onto it for them
like does the baby get a heat action ah
it's kind of cries and then like throws
up on someone I'd be into that I agree
and w10 for soap so pretty scheme is so
so pretty and that's that's still crazy
to think about though the fact that all
of the other games were on the same
engine yeah look that's the day they
reiterated it's sort of like yeah I'm
sort of design foundation still still
actually we can check out oh wait we
need another controller but yes Virtua
Fighter 5 employee leo is in here nice I
think I forgot to check out a show in
the other town was the karaoke so we're
going to yes so the thing I think that
brought me back into Yakuza is
definitely the karaoke it's like seeing
I'm pretty sure for a lot of people with
Yakuza 3 it was probably seeing like a
Giant Bomb QuickLook or something for it
because they they just they hit up a lot
of the really fun stuff in it and it
brought a lot of people kind of kind of
down with it but
like the karaoke seeing that is what
made me be like I should I should play
this again yes we have not worn out the
the thumbs up here though oh no that's
thumbnail the best thumb I hope that
like even though like we we have a
certain way we do review thumbs I hope
that we use it for the review and that's
it's the best thumb of Q use thumb I've
ever seen let's go ahead and mark the
karaoke there's also mahjong and do
sweep over just like mahjong oh wait
oh ho here we go okay I mean sorry it's
a yin-yang cafe okay and it's on the way
where we head over there
Sega Jakob says today is a diamond go
for an extra scene in there oh yeah
that's the is that your jam that's the
jam woohoo
so can this town a little bit like even
when he's like when he walks by people
I've noticed like sometimes he like
turning like look at him and stuff like
it's huh you check out a while Jackson
grab a bite of fried chicken
Oh specials the wild burger wild hot
chicken in an orange juice that's he oh
man he is going in all they got a wild
avocado burger in here so all these
points all these different attributes
are used as essentially your upgrade
currency Oh
bring back the tropical dad shirts
that's curios most fitting aesthetic I
agree I loved I love tropical qu it's
being able to go inside these buildings
are such a nice touch oh yeah let's take
the flag it's time to throw down
right into this sign oh I love it
it's true he needs all those calories
just for all the punching running and
baby handling he does I didn't even have
a chance to get the fight into the
restaurant oh well next time
well we'll hit it up put it up the right
way it seemed like that like I don't
think I've ever seen that screen up over
there at the end of the street oh yeah
oh oh here's
you know Hyuk is a tradition so you've
got a giant comb you gotta use the giant
comb I blocked everything
all those poor people who are trying to
eat their burgers
where's our thug he's look this guy's
crazy he just punched through that glass
I don't want anything to do with that
we're just gonna saunter over here at
the wall what is happening see we can
chase me upstairs
let's wreck some havoc up here oh my god
this crazy man in a white shirt just
came into the upstairs and started
punching the air picked up a table I
don't understand it but it happened what
is this
can we take the table all the way
downstairs oh no okay here anyways like
this is weird man I'm out no thank you
this is a little border diner moment he
just gave up to go punch him go punch
him anyway I want to see how upset this
lady is we just fixed this place and you
came and ruined it again
okay so here we go let's sing this is
this the whole playlist that we have
that we're about to see is there more
song I'd like to thank us more songs but
there's some there's a good selection to
start I like it I mean any any time you
do karaoke it's just a good time brain
here we go he's a diamond for crow
tonight look it's a little mode you do
down there shilling so there's a there's
an extra scene in here
there we go get you're warming up again
ready well I'm gonna be absolutely
silent for this time I try not to talk I
we turn up the water to you know be sure
to address our fans oh I'll talk I'll
talk say yeah I'm gonna give you a
little bit more the game sound
[Music]
[Music]
I kept into the fury of UIC
Oh
[Music]
she's 37 yet to me the she I just kind
of said that he is
I'm sure can fix that
you have someone else Pataki I'm gonna
come in we go ah
[Music]
yeah that's a GameSpot thumbnail it's
really something
unconsciously smiling
not my baby
[Music]
yeah
I love it calculating rank what you get
no it's pretty good
all right you know a karaoke avatar oh
man
the singer your tenth in the whole of
the whole the whole whole area Oh people
singing though I feel like there are
more people who are doing karaoke all
you get to do it do you want to do
another one or you get out of there so
good sorry I'm very happy we all got to
share that together make sure we visit
the cafe the onion cafe yes this is new
territory for me
I'm aware that this cafe was available
this early so we'll see how this goes a
new experience for all excuse me
here you does it all fight sings and
looks after by these guys oh hey hey you
hey Oh No
I like how the camera like pulls in just
like show you how absolutely Bruhl
everything you're doing is it's a very
good lunch yeah I know we mentioned it
earlier in the stream but for real
though why is here you not in Tekken 7
the character makes so much sense
well the ping pong minigame in 3 was
very good
there's just so much town right even
just even in the alleys why do they have
the cat cafe on with the back alley
doesn't seem like a place you'd put a
cat cafe already back alley I think it's
one of the entrances are here out front
I think you go down probably go down
into it this looks like the entrance to
a great experience
there's no cats here take it back
I actually made a song for Yakuza zero
oh snap which one I'm gonna I'm gonna
totally I'm I'm in I like this
not finished yet still who should be a
good time I'm excited oh wait here's
another internet cafe it's the same
company that had the chatting so this
this looks like it's parking we the same
girls yes okay see this this looks like
the type of place you'd go for ham show
there's a lot like cubicle set up and
stuff I don't
not that I'm insinuating anything
oh you using our wholesome boy oh we go
to one cat cafe doesn't have cats are we
having to solve the mystery of the
missing cats and the cat cafes every
right to be pissed
do ya this is your main hook your main
alert why are you doing we're the cats
that's a good sub-story jingle okay
catless cat cafe welcome sir so the cat
cafe what is this place it's just my
dude this regular ps4 a pro gameplay
this is a regular ps4 regular regular
ps4 there is a cat here she just didn't
see it I adore my feline friends trust
me friend
gathered a few adorable four of them
respected me you know you know earning a
cat's respect is very important yeah
it's true you've got to have good cow
use crying over spilt milk
[Music]
one of those butchers in the hallway are
all the cats he had paw pals palak O's
Monster Hunter so looks like I gotta
find some cats are you try your tracking
down cats yo this cat likes Kiryu I have
been chosen Oh cat that cat good with
babies is good with beatdowns he's good
with cats friend cats like his x-men
superpower frankly I mean I don't know
if you want nice so it's a really good
way to do it if I find cats I'll bring
them back to your cafe how many cats do
they want bring some food reaches
maximum affection no it's a cat dating
game okay that's a good time
it's trapped don't pet that cat's belly
don't Pat that cat I look at all those
pictures of those cats yeah their needs
anymore
Yeah right what's up here
yes so I think one of the benefits of
this engine is just like how many
seemingly innocuous areas you can just
access in the game now you're up on the
rooftop area it seems well yes and we
have a sakes we have their safes later
throughout the city and it's a matter of
finding keys for them
oh so it's kind of like the UH like the
keys that you'd find scattered around
for the lockers to before okay are the
lockers backer is that just taking the
place of them I have not found lockers I
think it's just safe okay I'm into it
that was real smooth I'm into that I
will let's see I think we could go to
convenience stores and grab some snacks
for the kitties
see I bought Yakuza five I hope it's a
fun game it's a good time euros a long
game - it's very when I finished I ended
up rushing through like kind of the end
because I wanted to be ready for 6:00
and this is before the little I got
announced and I wish I knew that I had
more time but I ended up clocking in at
around 60 hours 65 hours so there's a
lot a lot of good game in there a lot of
good scenes I think you'll have a good
time with five five guys one of my
favorite Kiryu storylines - you know I
love about vending machines in Japan
there are cold and if you look at the
bottom hot drinks hot drinks are great
especially if you know on cold days
wrong automatic hand warmers is the
spice life as they say
I'm gonna try Yakuza I I'm excited for
you
Ricky and I hope you have a good time
with it it's still one of my favorite
series so excited to finally play six
it's gonna be a good time here we go
give me that that's sweet sweet jam it's
also really weird to be able to walk
around in the back of these because
before it was like I was like two camera
angles the I've actually been to the one
in this location I believe is either
five or six stories real and it is about
this cramped where where is the cat food
you know you want those boomerang briefs
I don't know if I do fair enough let's
see let's go mouth guard restraining
gear you're going in on cat food
my entire inventory Yakuza zero was just
Mountain Dew cans for the longest time
because I could do it
Jack was the sixes lit I agree Omar
could operate some skills
all right we are going to see if we
could mmm let's see the sub-stories it's
in trouble
Asian knots I don't know why the cat
mission is not part of my task list I
think it probably is just because it's
like that thing that you're supposed to
happen into it's an ongoing thing yeah
oh here's poyo poyo oh hey here's Virtua
Fighter virtual Photoshop oh it is final
should not very good at this but that's
fine uh so it's Vanessa Vanessa Williams
is like my character in this one not
Vanessa Vanessa Williams
you have a secret is a sinner in Virtua
Fighter 5 Vanessa Lewis I think it's
been a long time
ok Virtua Fighter 5 I think it's Vanessa
Lewis it's like a dress her up to look
like Meryl from Metal Gear which was
really rad yeah Vanessa there we go is
there good Brad's good dude
Elle blaze also a very good dude this
this is literally just the game I love
this oh you're a go man
go boy I'm actually not a anyone oh man
ok he's a cool dude he's got he's got
really strong punches
hi guys how are you doing great Nathan
how are you doing yourself the ultimate
showdown here yo Nathan's got my back
it's Louis we we've figured it out and I
don't have to be as embarrassed anymore
because I said the wrong name
so Virtua Fighter 5 is actually like a
super technical game like in terms of
like fighting stuff which is pretty
pretty cool that this whole game is in
here and like it's running at 60 fps and
is this is really impressive I like it I
take it to the sumo ring
looks like I should sip up his jacket
yeah maybe nice greens from Seattle or
Seattle's a great place is this online
playable I'm not sure a couch co-op
there you can heat up your friends Sarah
Bryant's a good character big fan
burnt dead or alive now - oh thanks for
stopping by Jacob it was nice hanging
out take it easy
she's good sampling yeah so there you go
you got a whole Virtua Fighter game in
there if you want to do more beat downs
in a one-on-one type of situation
yeah and in between look and during the
loading screens you have a few factoids
about the lore of the series
get yourself a refresher I think now
would actually be a good time to go back
oh no michi and check out two other
minigames all right I'm in one of the
coolest fighting games around I agree I
like it it's it's definitely up there
for 3d fighters for me
there's driving in five I remember right
so Mikkel if you're looking for for some
driving I I can say with certainty that
there is driving in Yakuza 5 just
because of the way that that game is is
structured with its story two different
types of driving - so what is your
favorite y'all cuz I anyway then I think
three cuz it's the one that like really
got me into it
and I really like that that story but
like I also like for cuz it it
introduced me to Akiyama fives got some
really memorable moments but I think
three three wins now for me I also
haven't finished so check this out
we're going fishing he's so confident I
would not stand on the boat like that
you know we need to do a supercut of all
the times he just takes off a shirt and
you weren't wearing a wetsuit under
there
giryu what are you doing that's not Oh
spear gun fishing so in a case of
minigames within minigames one of the
ways you can be better at this
spearfishing minigame is to get better
spear guns and I learned that one of the
ways to do that is to impress people in
bars
I guess people who people in bars own
really good spear guns oh go to a barn
you show off your spear but there is in
the bars there is a conversational
minigame oh is that is that the other
one we're gonna hit up after this to
kind of like uh actually no we're gonna
check out something else but this is a
non rail shooter where I'm actually not
showing not doing so well right now in
terms of illustrating how to be an
efficient reloader
but if you fire with with an empty
cartridge the reloading animation takes
longer so it is in your best interest to
reload before firing again okay so
there's a little bit of depth in there
for that I really like how the game kind
of like does that like half second of
slow motion when you hit something and
that transition to the wetsuit is
something I'm still thinking about that
was real it's gonna mess me up
can see why people call this series of
spiritual successor to the Shenmue
series there's there's some similarities
in there that's it's pretty good we're
getting a new shenmue ii totally forgot
about that
that's a shark that's a shark I wouldn't
have shot it
I looked operable oh just headbutt just
hit you in the in the nose just kind of
kind of pops you a little bit I would do
this IRL goop we just saw that shark I
wouldn't shoot a shark in real life
shimmer throughout this year I'll be
apprehensive about I don't know if it'll
actually make it this year but thinking
I don't I haven't been keeping up on my
my backer emails
well the hell's going on now it's a it's
a fishing minigame we're swimming around
in the in the bay and we're shooting our
spear gun it's
what of course just copy bossfights of
this okay yeah that makes sense I mean
it doesn't make sense but it makes sense
with swift projectiles what is even do
they know about this on the fish fish
boat tours like once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity come fight the great squid
that lives inside of our bay and this is
just the beginner mode oh saying there
are bigger squids yes Oh premium Lea
nice
I'll have the calamari please kiri
really knows how to manage his breath
yeah right look at the hall for added
immersion look at the poor Blowfish on
the right hold hold your breath wall qu
holds his breath and see see how long
you can go oh boy
oh you level up your fishing or fetch
spearing your spearfishing
thank you guys for streaming you ku6
it looks like an awesome game happy to
play who's at any time Ken Ken yahooza
and you can you get paid and weapons
that's the best currency I like all of
my payment in guns please how about
swimming in the game I don't know if you
actually go swimming outside of like
what we just did I have not noticed any
swimming yeah it's not it's not been a
thing that you normally need to do I
need to get back our is this on console
or PC this is PlayStation 4 exclusive
for now right now we're gonna explore
and I'll meet you a little bit as I get
to I guess this town's equivalent of a
home base and I I love the baby but I'm
glad that we're able to advance the plot
where we don't want to run we don't we
don't need the baby all the time it's
nice so you know be grounded and have
that
kind of thing but I'm still trying to
take in the fact that he's not wearing
his jacket we're so close to getting
back to the Hawaiian shirt I almost came
to the livestream wearing a red button
down shirt
oh yeah shut up I don't read what
cosplay I mean if you want to cosplay as
anyone Kosmic here use is a great choice
he's such a rad dude this was answered a
while ago because it's preoccupied but
holiday collectibles so we I guess the
the safes are collectible yes I mean
this game is not short of collectibles
but cats are collectibles I mean you
know if you want temper your
expectations
you know don't expect I wouldn't expect
a game as large as five because you're
only like playing his one character yeah
five was if I was huge yeah almost
intimidatingly so so you I'd be so into
it if they ported this to PC in the
switch cosplays majr swear a us like a
snakeskin jacket in an eyepatch ha sign
me up
so this is the the clan creator stuff
okay I'm excited to see this this is how
it's tied to the wrestlers I believe oh
so there's a little bit of a light
strategy component to Yakuza 6 where you
basically I guess essentially run a gang
let's I've got different stats and
different skills it looks like these are
your most dependable boys I'd say so
nice and I've played this a couple times
like you know an RTS there are different
units that have different benefits
different pluses and minuses in this
case I've learned after playing this
enough times I've learned to try to
prioritize your heavies because they
move pretty slowly so I'm gonna get
money my heavies out in the field first
and you can see like how much their unit
cost is oh wow and plus how quickly I
guess your bar fills up and you know
it's all about managing when you send
out all your different enemies so the
kind of this is kind of like you're
you're saying that sort of like on a
track to get two guys across the way
right okay all right
and then you have your lieutenants here
who actually have their own benefits
this guy here has what they call s is a
feeling which I guess will heal some
units nearby but we don't really need
that right now so if they seem to be
holding your oh yeah they're doing
pretty well and while we stuff all these
extra units I can alway tell you reach
50 so I can get my third lieutenant out
this is such a like a this is a weird
thing but I'm like really into it I I'm
not exactly sure why but I like it go
ahead and send a couple more grunts this
is so I can't I say it kind of looks
like a like a tower offence kind of
thing like like you're saying Swan
because you're you're sending dudes out
to attack other guys who are kind of
like in a defensive position or going
triggering healing and I'll trigger a
dropkick as well ah yes the ultimate
dropkick is on the ground so that like
are they all kind of like down the
street or do you get like different
settings for different like look closer
everyone's so stoked
you actually it's a oh I like that
better pause that's real good like
wonder if he's like applauding the
opposing team yeah I feel like the good
sportsmanship honorable like you tried
real hard but you guys couldn't beat up
our guys oh yes and one of the things
about Onomichi print in particular is
that the game encourages you to talk to
everyone because anyone you meet could
potentially be a clan member that looks
like a thing I could probably spend a
lot of time and I probably will so I
think we could spend the last few
minutes of this stream just exploring
the rural charm of Onomichi
just taking in the sights I just I'm
still trying to get over how how good
this game looks white are thugs
this guy in the red shirt beat him up
just a bunch of threatening men just try
to punch you and it didn't go
I was minding my own business visiting
the shrine it's trying to have a good
time think I pull out a sword
alright I'll try to get his sword there
we go thrown downstairs close enough
I'll take you can you recruit new
members for the gang minigame by
completing other quests yes there you go
got you Ken Ken does a very
anticlimactic finishing blow with a
sword it works oh we're gonna do stat
that's that oh that's a nice feature
ah so you get little little buffs though
I imagine someone like walking up to one
of those statues and like pouring out
one of those those health drinks on it
they're just being like ah he did acuity
hunger moving an army cells before she
does shoe polish oh yeah I don't like
fighting on an empty stomach - it's true
no one's home in this game you can chat
with real Japanese porn star we did it
earlier so it's an adventure if you want
to check it out it's back there katana
hype feeling it like it so how big is
this area compared to camera Cho would
you say a little bit smaller kind of
similar just a hair smaller yeah yes
that feels like it's just a little
smaller but that's that's pretty alright
still detailed and there's a lot of
businesses in this building and you can
walk into that building and probably
walk into all those all of them most of
them okay there's a little safe yep are
there any pre-order bonuses I don't know
if there are bonuses for pre-ordering I
know that there's a special edition that
comes with some cool stuff I'm very
excited to get that this looks like my
favorite karaoke bar it's kind of say if
someone left the door open
jeez there's no one here there's
actually a story event i know that
actually occurs here okay
Oh couple more thugs what dudes just
kind of strolling through the street
minding our own business singing out and
then the city dude ends up
geez straight into it I'm really glad
they brought in like the Giant Swing
moves you oh man like that ragdoll
physics stuff that's that's also doing
it for me frustrated that Sega deleted
again there's probably something that
they're trying to work out and I trust
them
and their call for it it could be like a
like a patch or like a change who knows
but we're at least getting that demo
that carries over progress so that'll
hopefully be enough to kind of take us
over and the prologue is a very meaty
prologue and as I said it will also
include a chunk of the first chapter
there you go April 17th woof that is a
ways away
I love how this is designed like many
many countless shopping districts in
Japan so my roommate actually went to
Japan a while ago and the one thing he
said was I can't believe how accurate
all this stuff is mmm
like he I was walking down an area while
I was playing five and he was like oh
this is I swear I've been here like I
was here when I was visiting and it's
it's kind of really rad that it's that
clothes won't get any sake fair enough
see any info on Youku jock who's a 5 2
through 5 remasters there's a to
remaster coming out in Japan
no word on it being here yet but it
would be really cool if we got yes which
actually runs on the Dragon engine I
mean I guess Sega also has an
opportunity to eat old to improve the
first co-op game because that one was
not designed on the dragon engine so we
got another tumblr alert who her creepy
rumor that some grave robbers have been
sighted in the cemetery geez talk about
feudal era crimes right I check it I
check but hell no man hell no so there
don't deserve that we're gonna put a
stop to a grave robbers you go go beat
those boys up not on Q's watch this
shrine where is the graveyard I think is
it there is it right that's up by a let
me triple check oh yeah it's sure up
that way okay put a stop to those grave
robbers we are within market there let's
go
these guys want to fight alert some
dudes and not today I've got to stop
crime
taking the sights like a vigilante
stopping all sorts of bad and they're
still chasing me gluttonous we'll
probably have a long demo cheese from
cheers from Brazil I'm also glad Igor
so we're the robbers a grave incident
for the grave robbers are they are those
them back there
you're like talk to them like hey cut it
out no we've been found out catch every
last one of them
oh boy are you doing like the running
minigame I guess so say where did the
fur that one's real quick where'd he go
I mean what's the right looks like pick
this way I'll go back back up but kind
of like so I think through the the pink
dots on the maps like off to the left up
here when you're not getting away just
do it
shady man it's a shady man
all right that's one two to go there's
no one else over there all the little
animations like how he just did that
that arm I'm really diggin
I only have to finish yeah cuz a five
and I'm all set for six do it Alexander
I believe in you I was in the same boat
like a week ago
what she's just I just pulled his leg
tripped him down the stairs that's the
real dick move
okay so where's the other guy up over
that way just run down the hill autumn
marker on you so I'll never lose you yep
I'll talk to the kid the new release
game time is April 17th
there's a reference to pocket circuit
fighter and he's learning English oh
that means eight right oh you actually
don't care about learning English so
yeah this is a callback to actually
yoga's a zero dance because I believe
pocket fighter talking racing fighter
was one of the minigames yeah yeah look
at the circuit fighter that's really
cool bad influence we get call backs all
the way the first game no not the focus
on one yucca zero it's yeah it's there
[Music]
so it's my small toy cars yes this toy
car racing that's all it is
yeah so I guess one of the minigames is
bonding with that kid over sweet car
racing things nice thing it's the clock
oh it stopped didn't come your countdown
why can't I forward this video because
this video is live okay it's just
staring at a wall like the end of Blair
Witch Project well I mean if you don't
see his face you might not recognize him
you know maybe that's what he's kind of
looking for can noobs that never played
an early entry in the series fully enjoy
and understand the story in six I'd say
so because as I said earlier there's in
the main menu you can actually get quick
summaries of the previous games and at
the same time one of the beauties of the
Yakuza games is that each of them can be
appreciated there you go two three peeps
another tumblr event I guess some dude
rolled up into the cemetery took out the
whole gang of grave robbers who serve
bigger balls than I do okay dang Kevin
i'ma tell you with a hundred percent
certainty I will be playing Yakuza 6 on
the 17th instead of God of War
personally I'm not trying to convince
anyone to do you know anything other
than they want but we have a preview of
this game now that we can show off but
hey you know there do you play what you
want to play have a good time is it okay
to start with Yakuza zero I've never
played a Yakuza game yes
yeah cuz as arrows a great starting
point very very good entry point now
we're reaching a ninety minutes I think
now it might might be a good time to
wrap up yeah yeah sure I'm down so guys
thanks again for watching throughout
this week you will see some yoga
coverage and that will culminate with
our history of feature but I considering
that the games not out till April we
might have a little bit more
previews lined up but stay tuned and
again thanks for joining us for this
yeah and I guess this is where strength
saying goodbye
yes but fire everybody hi guys
[Music]